هذا واعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه توصل
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع الى
اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار في جميع انحاء
السودان لاربعه وعشرين ساعه بدا من
السادسه من صباح غد السبت وقالت الوزاره
ان الطرفين سيلتزمان بموجب الاتفاق بوقف
الهجمات والقصف المدفعي والجوي وعدم
استخدام الطائرات المسيره وتحريك القوات
او اعاده التمركزها او امدادها كما اتفق
الطرفان وفق الرياض على السماح بحريه
الحركه لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه لجميع
انحاء البلاد واكلت الوزاره ان الرياض
وواشنطن اقترحتا هذه الهدنه لتيسير وصول
المساعدات وكسر حاله العنف
مضيفتنا لعدم التزام الطرفين بهذه الهدنه
سيضطرهما الى تاجيل محادثات جده
معنى من الخرطوم مراسله الجزيره اسامه
سيدي احمد اسامه اشتباكات متواصله وانباء
عن هدنه ثم ظهور لشمس الدين الكباشي يؤكد
ان البرهان يقود العمليات كيف يمكن وضع
ذلك في السياق العام للمشهد السوداني
لما في ظل التطورات
العامه فيما يتعلق بهذه الحرب المستمره
منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل الماضي والتطورات
الميدانيه المتلاحقه التي تشهدها جبهات
قتاليه متعدده ومتنوعه في ولايه الخرطوم
كان هناك تحليق للطيران الحربي مستمر منذ
الصباح الباكر وحتى الساعات القليله
الماضيه بحسب مصادر يعني اكدت ان الطيران
الحربي السوداني قام بقصف اهداف في منطقه
جنوب ام درمان وكذلك اكد هذا المصدر ان
القوات
الطيران الحربي قام بقصف معسكر تابع لقوات
الدعم السريع في منطقه صالحه الذي تقع
جنوب منطقه ام درمان اذا التطورات متلاحقه
ميدانيه اشتعال لجبه القتال المتعدده ما
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
اخر هذه التطورات ربما وتاثيرات المتلاحقه
الدخان لاشتعال الدخان الارتفاع اعمده
الدخان لليوم الثالث على التوالي من منطقه
المستودعات الرئيسيه والمخزون
مخازن الوقود والغاز التي تقع جنوب منطقه
الخرطوم التي ايضا هي تعد واحده من
الجبهات القتال ومسرح للمواجهات المستمره
في هذه المنطقه خاصه وان هناك كانت هناك
معارك ضاريه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع في هذه المنطقه وفي محيطها
كذلك
منطقه ايضا
المنطقه التي ايضا شهدت هذه المواجهات
كذلك عدد من الاحياء في هذه المنطقه مت
لمنطقه المواجهات ما يجعل التحذيرات
الداخليه مستمره
للمواطنين الذين
وجهوا الذين دعت جهات عديده ان تبعد من
هذه من محيط هذا المكان لاستمرار على
الحرب واستمرار الخطوره الامنيه على من
يقتلون هذه المنطقه الان في هذه اللحظات
ايضا الطيران الحربي يحلق في سماء واسعه
من ولايه الخرطوم يعني ان استمرار هذه
الحرب لا يزال الطرفان فيما يبدو انها
طرفان هي خوضان هذه المعركه
للكسب الميداني لجبهات القتال المتعدده
وهذه هذه الحرب المستمره ان نتحدث عن
تداعيات انسانيه
مستمره سواء هنا في الخرطوم
والجبهات القتاليه التي شهدتها هذه
الاشتباكات او
عدد من الولايات الاخرى التي ايضا هي كانت
متاثره بشكل مباشر في الاستمرار هذه